[Music]
hello we are continuing with our survey
of the national birds of
latin american countries and we are here
in continuing with the caribbean
that this tray here has national birds
of
uh most we're missing maybe a couple of
the
caribbean islands and i apologize for
that uh
so start here with the northern of the
greater antilles and the island of cuba
cuba selected the trogon this is a
beautiful
species and even has the colors matching
the
cuban flag
[Music]
the cuban name is tokoro
or tokoro
the bird actually does have a
vocalization that sounds like this
and the tail is entirely unique
there is no dragon species with this
sort of nicely carved
tail the related species
of trogon is found on the island of
hispaniola
and so here's the hispaniolan trogon
this one was chosen
as a national bird by the country of
haiti and there
they call it calison rouge or caulson
wooj
and here this is a male
and same as with the cuban trogon
species that is found in forested but
more open
habitats and nests in three cavities
sometimes abundant woodpecker holes
and relatively common both species are
still in in good shape
not endangered on the same island of
hispaniola
the country of the dominican republic
republica dominicana
chose the palm chat to be their national
bird and
the reason for this is that this is
really part of the landscape one of the
most common birds
i recently visited the country of the
dominican republic and got to see them
everywhere and
their nests their massive fortresses of
sticks
there are communal nests found
throughout the country
in on telephone poles on in trees but
mostly in palms
sometimes even on rocks i've seen nests
and
this bird is a unique kind of enigmatic
phylogenetically it's closest related to
north american wax wings
but it's a single member of its family
so it's a good choice for a national
bird
then if we move to the next island to
the east
to puerto rico this bird
the spindalis was chosen as a national
bird
let me see it's called reynita mora
in puerto rico or reynamora
or sigua another name i found and in
english it used to be called
striped headed tanager for obvious
reason it has a lot of stripes
but now we know that it's not really
close related to tanagers
it's a unique caribbean lineage and
there are four species
on different islands and this one is
endemic to puerto rico
then moving over to jamaica in jamaica
this
gorgeous hummingbird was chosen as a
national bird
it's called by jamaican's doctor bird or
dr hummingbird
i'm not i couldn't find a good
explanation for this name but
the male has spectacularly long
tail and in flight must be a pleasure to
see
and strangely enough uh birds in the
eastern part of the country have black
bells and the rest of the country
red bulls this one here is a bit faded
but it used to be
a red-billed bird and female is without
this
ornamental feathers in the tail and a
little bit smaller
but it's still a common bird not
endangered
then uh let's maybe look at oh yeah
maybe
here the parrots so three different
caribbean
countries uh insular countries chose
parrots for their national birds
let's maybe look at this one first this
is the largest of the
member of the genus amazona imperial
parrot appropriately named and this
great bird is endemic to the island of
dominica
and there it's called it's called cicero
it's an endangered species there are
only fewer than 200 individuals left in
the wild
and not too many in captivity so
this one has to be watched and cared for
managed carefully
the neighboring island of saint lucia
chose
their own amazon totally differently
colored
but still quite colorful and also
it's not very common let's see that the
name
they chose for it local name is uh
jacquard
or jack what i'm i think it's jacques
and in this case there are fewer than
500 birds left in the wild
and both of these birds are in the
mountains in the interior of the island
so hopefully inaccessible and hopefully
the habit will be preserved
and then the third of these amazons of
the caribbean
this parrot here called saint vincent
parrot on
the island of saint vincent in the
grenadines has
two different color morphs green and
yellow and
here we have a representative of the
green
and these birds are a little bit more
common not as endangered as the other
two
i mentioned before but still it's a
relatively small
published in small island and a little
lower in this case not
in the mountains then
we go to island of aruba
where interestingly two birds were
chosen for the national bird first it
was the
choco locally named borrowing owl
subspecies endemic to
aruba and the second one more recently
this little parakeet brown throated
parakeet which
there is called prikichi
uh probably onomatopoeic probably after
the call
and i guess the reason for this switch
was to bring attention to this bird that
maybe is in
more need of conservation and that's why
the country brings
attention to it and finally i know not
finally but
we are traveling further south this is
now trinidad
and two birds here because trinidad
island has the scarlet ibis chosen as
their national bird
and the island of tobago
has this chachalaka this is
one of the guanz chicken-like birds
and this one is called roofos tailed
rafikauda in latin because of this nice
rufus-tipped tail and also the belly is
just not colored
this specimen is maybe not the nicest
the ibis is a common sight
throughout trinidad and it's a marsh
bird
nesting in big colonies and often seen
in flocks
traveling from the feeding grounds to
the to their nests
and i then will move to these two big
birds
so the island of barbados in the country
of barbados let me see here
chose the brown pelican as their
national bird
so here maybe actually this view this is
a species that is
pretty widely distributed not only in
caribbean islands but also in
southern united states and it's a
colonial nestor that
i mean everybody talks about egg
thinning and
endangerment of the raptors but this
bird also suffered quite a bit in 1950s
1970s from the
use of ddt and from
the pesticides and egg thinning
and finally here is the bird
chosen by the country of antigua and
barbuda
and this is the magnificent magnificent
frigate bird
sometimes called man of war this is one
of the seabirds
famous for its behavior of stealing
food from other birds can steal fish or
some other oh but they can also catch
their own fish they can put
up for example snap flying fish
from there and this bird carries a male
in life
this would be a bright red inflatable
sack and the males
on the breeding grounds would inflate
this to attract females females don't
have this
inflatable sac and i will end by saying
that
one cool kind of record that this bird
also
beats is that uh frigate bird's skeleton
is
lighter than the feathers if you
actually plucked all the feathers and
combine them
the skeleton is so pneumatized and so
light fused
that it's lighter so that's a pretty
good choice
also for the national bird